aloha
hello everyone it's your girl and i'm
coming to
january that's not a place
in january i'm coming to salt lake city
i'm coming to nashville and then we're
going to raleigh north carolina austin
indianapolis and philadelphia get
tickets at esther on ice.com i cannot
wait
hey slugs come see me live in january
i'll be in edmonton canada i'll be in
milwaukee wisconsin i'll be in naples
and tampa florida and then in february
i'll be in springfield missouri
washington dc and westminster canada
there's a lot more dates coming up i'll
be in san francisco austin a bunch of
other places you're going to go to
andyletterman.com shows to find those
out can't wait to meet you can't wait to
sign some shirts for you let's go carlos
[Music]
what are you wearing your vaccine
band-aids that's why i just asked her
proof that she doesn't actually shower
is right there it's proof that she
doesn't shower or that she's faking
getting the vaccine and is like trying
to it's a show-off it also looks like a
fake
doesn't look like she made it herself i
had you're reminding me i have not
showered since well actually i don't
shower take baths
there's no bath in the hotel
it's actually a problem can i take a
bath at this woman's house that we're at
ask her
she's already asked if the husband of
her husband will look at our vaginas and
see if we're good candidates for a
little back story guys we're here in
beautiful kailua
oahu
welcome to our very special hawaiian
episode
dude this is my camera um i do not feel
good here
i don't like hawaii esther do you
realize that there's about to be rain
for five days straight this is the only
sun we're getting i've never ever
happened what do you mean you don't like
hawaii i've never sneezed and stuffed up
more i feel like [ __ ] i landed i got my
period
it's like kind of hot i don't know it's
just my allergies are so bad
nobody cares or believes you
how does that feel to have nothing no
sympathy it feels exactly like my
childhood and i feel scared i really am
trying to like muster
like an ounce of sympathy for you but
somehow can't get there tell me what is
your honest reaction then about what i
just how i just complained just being
very she's probably very not surprised
very is this to me it's on brand okay
yeah you're my little baby okay yeah
and i gave you allergy meds thank you
when those kick in it's gonna be rock
and roll i gave her allergies that's so
weird
i said lord
make her suffer
this is like being with mom and dad like
you guys give me that my dad or mom your
dad for sure
i'm big mom energy
am i father
i don't know i'm stumped i'm dead
yeah she's fun dad i'm like i'm
i'm worried
because mori you guys do the you do
you go do the crime yeah you do the yeah
you do the show together
yeah all right so kyle where are we
we we took kalila airlines
my big joke at 5 a.m yesterday
she's been saving
she hasn't she hasn't spoken to us or
hung out with us because she wants to
save that joke for when she sees us i
want to get to know that so we got in
yesterday
we flew in on the 7 a.m flight why
esther almost missed the flight
i didn't i look i i was really becoming
the late person no no no no i don't miss
flights also i even though i thought i
was gonna be late today i was there
before you oh but you woke up to work
out you guys had the secret workout
well here here you and i were supposed
to go on a walk this morning but then it
was followed up with a i'm really not
doing well with my allergies text so i
was like hey annie we're working out wow
i didn't know first of all i'll be
second that's fine i can work out alone
i don't
need it you were invited on the walk
what of course you were you were you
were to be invited on the walk i thought
it wasn't gonna be invited i thought it
was a family walk but yeah everybody you
bailed so then annie i'm like we're not
gonna go on a walk yeah we're gonna go
work out she showed up and by the way to
work out in crocs
that's how little she respects you she
just doesn't give a [ __ ] well she's like
i don't know she's an island girl she's
used to just clinging to trees with her
feet oh and on my way to the workout a
really hot boy and a bicycle hit on me
you made him sound very young just now
you called him a boy a boy on a bicycle
he was like i there's i work at a coffee
shop that just opened it's called brew
and foam but he was
tall we got to go to brewing foam i
think we have to go find this hot
balloon we're filming for that i think i
know why you like hawaii why because you
if i was a person on vacation in hawaii
you're the person i would want to have
sex with okay so she is a person on
vacation in hawaii and she does want to
have sex with her
i don't mean it like that the number's
crunch
[Laughter]
i just want to say that this is day two
i was
kalyala now kallio does come out here i
do do people know that kalila comes to
hawaii once a week
one time a week kalila comes to hawaii
she flies back just to do the podcast i
think that's just about right it's cool
i i support it but
i thought there was going to be i i'm
not a red carpet but like i thought
there would be some sort of
plan of
kalila was just gone
okay kelila got a different ride from
the airport then i was like she wasn't
she's not in our hotel oh we found out
she set us up to stay at a hotel and
that she's not there
she sent me and annie up at the same
hotel but she's staying at a different
one but we find out when we get here
tell me that's not shade
it's shady okay wait not only is that
shady but
we booked these flights i don't get
first class to stay with these stupid
[ __ ] scrubs together though we did
something together
that was
in the last row
now
okay now
kalyla
had the window seat todd and i were in
the middle seats and then there was one
empty seat because jules was supposed to
come and couldn't come
that seat did not get filled esther came
up and she goes oh
oh i'll just switch to here and kalila
said no that's for my feet
[Laughter]
should i ditch carlos larger items
no these are for my legs
and that is so good that is so good
because i do think my feet and esther
are like equivalent
that is true aloha spirit right there
but then she really did use them for her
feet and i thought it was like funny
we'll be chatting over her feet
she was watching cartoons the whole time
watching cartoons and you were talking
to me while a very important character
was dying i did look down and i saw it
did look i went oh i am interrupting
quite a part
but i tried to talk to her the entire
flight you did yeah i was excited we're
going to hawaii kalaila has all the
stuff planned i can't wait to hear about
it this is why she didn't want to talk
but nothing planned
i do have things planned for myself
you know what's great though is that i
don't want to do [ __ ]
so i'm like
hang loose
awesome look the the weather just isn't
in our favor well it's perfect right now
it's been almost perfect the whole time
actually todd and i went on a beautiful
hike yesterday did i not send you there
you did i just wasn't present
no she wasn't there i thought she'd be
at the top i thought the lighthouse was
you i thought wouldn't that be a fun
surprise you popped out
i was chasing the sun yesterday so as
soon as i got here i was like oh let me
see if i can get a dive in because it's
going to be raining the next four days
and so i drove to the west side and uh
it was rough and so i couldn't get a
dive in but that's the reason why i
ditched you guys but she was like it's
so beautiful out here she sent me a
picture of the west side we didn't have
a car they wanted one car okay
she was no that's enough for all of us
we did have to we had to steal the car
we had to pry it out of georgia
i [ __ ] checked i'm not production
i am talent okay these are the [ __ ] i
rented the car i got every all of these
locations
i set up all of these locations somehow
i don't get production money which i
feel like i should at this point i just
to make no i have not complained no she
did it was in the room to me she goes if
this is a work vacation why am i paying
for it i'm like because there's no
studio paying for this it's all us
the production is up how is esther my
favorite person right now this is the
least the least difficult of everybody
here this is that she wanted you to pay
for her her trip no i didn't ask me for
it so i'm happy who did you think was
gonna pay for it no i would i'll all i
said was mr mr hollywood it's a work
trip but i paid
that's weird can i talk about let me
talk about the flight more so there was
a moment where esther came up
i bent her over the and this is like
people are still getting ready to go so
this is like still tense plane is still
boarding the plane's boarding the
steward does have [ __ ] to do they're
called flight attendants
stewardesses
i'm not even trying to pick a fight
tell me what stewardess is stewardess it
implies that you had to be a certain age
a certain height and then you had to be
unmarried isn't that crazy i know you
didn't know that
do you know their requirements in the
philippines
and now i say stewardess more proudly
okay because they should be a little
younger up until recently the
philippines still had the rule so for
philippine airlines you had to have a
look you had to be a certain height um i
think you had to be like at least five
six or five weren't you going to be one
am i oh yeah
yeah it's just a fantasy that was a role
play fantasy you and i have i sorry are
you upset because you were too short to
be a stewardess is that what you're
saying of course
yeah i'm too sure to be a rockette and
that's why i have this podcast with you
now but you make a great rock
a little pebble look at her how about my
that's what my dad calls me a pebble a
pebble in his shoe oh no that's what he
calls never mind that's what he calls my
sister
so we landed and the first thing esther
says
the first thing esther says when we land
is
i got my period i'm not doing well
and i do think while that is
a terrible thing to happen on day one of
vacation thank you i think it's a gift
i'd rather be on my period than about to
get then about to get my period i guess
it's like the fear of not knowing when
it's coming kind of sucks but day one is
my worst day by far
i like it's emergency mode all day so
it's just and i'm still recovering now
from day two is recover from day one
i don't know periods here's here's my
favorite part about it so todd and i go
by the room thinking maybe we can just
like get them to go to dinner with us or
something like
we're here together right let's do
something
so
we get to the room
okay
carlos and esther are tucked in tight
they're not there's not even they're not
going to a vending machine okay
nothing's happening
and they're watching
of all the things you can watch the news
they're just bleeding out watching the
news
watching cases on the rise like school
shooters everywhere i'm like no no no
this is the worst vacation but to esther
this is a
upgrade to last week when she was here
i'm gonna go ahead and make the
conclusion that the three of us have
very different vacation styles yeah
um i like to have fun
correct what kind of fun new things
anything yeah you are i'll do anything
anyone tells me to do i'll go open your
mouth and close your eyes
you're
[Laughter]
let me shower first you hit the ground
running annie
you are somebody who was like i want to
do it all
jam pack my day
i want to just
you know live fast day young and i love
that style esther i would say you are
the complete opposite an antithesis to
her entire existence and i would say
you're on the you're on the phone trying
to get that ticket back yes how do i get
i don't even know how to vacation i
there's three places there's three
cities i'll be in
la
new york
and i guess skokie's technically a
village
a village you know skokie's the world's
largest village wow that makes sense it
takes a village
to raise an esther i don't raise a slug
you gotta beat those three places and
nothing really does
i will say this
california los angeles i do believe and
come at me texas we know you hate us is
the best place i love where i live i
love my home so when i travel places i'm
always like huh i could be in malibu
well my dad nailed it last night on two
nights ago on the phone he said you he
said esther you can't
appreciate hawaii because you live in
l.a he said come spend the winter in
chicago and go to hawaii you will have a
great time i beg to differ oh i think
because i've lived in la so long is the
reason why i
cannot get enough of this island
it's just
la is so [ __ ] dry it's a chaperone
over here
your skin is good the hair is good
you're moisturized i don't need to wear
chapstick i can die whatever the [ __ ] i
want to dive not in cold water the water
here is warm all right listen i would
love to do all those fun things that you
but you're not invited here annie i have
extra dive gear i'm coming
we'll dive all right i'm wearing in the
rain and get staph infections i'll do it
all right i'll staph infection with you
carlos get the bed ready
carlos what are you huffing and puffing
time for the tuck-in oh that's right
carlos is with us guys he's here in a
different capacity as esther's handler
but
he's here nonetheless he really is
esther's handler and this is the fights
i used to get in with you this is what i
was like she was
slowly pushing me into handler mode i
was not
you you pushed yourself
there no i how could i push myself when
i'm wheeling you around in a wheelchair
it's like getting iced coffees and me
being like oh i'll take one too and is
it also like is it also um
is there a little bit of like cleaning
up period blood out of like the top
corner of the bathroom no but it's
existing
no it's more staying away from the
period my favorite thing about carlos is
he's divorced and he gets to hang out
that's when he gets all of the worst
parts of being married it's just like
seeing period everywhere just dealing
with the whining and then prepares you
for this i imagine you're also just a
human pillow on the plane
oh i have a video i look up and she goes
i drooled on you
and i looked down i was wearing navy
pants there's like it looks like a [ __ ]
stain
i listen i we know it wasn't toothpaste
um i
walked back to try to find you guys
couldn't find you no offense carlos
you're a little short and then i was
like where are i was like i don't see
them so then i waited and i went back
again
esther was
laying on you like she was you were
breastfeeding like you had fallen asleep
breastfeeding her
and it was it's like i have a video of
it
roll the clip um it was wild but i will
say this so before we when when we were
all still boarding i bent est over and i
was i was butt banging her into the seat
yes i had her ass up face down how i
like her
and the the flight attendant stopped she
goes did you say ass down face up yeah
our ass yeah
face up i do not like that
that is
[Music]
easy
wow klyla really loves that joke wow
jealous interesting you should try
comedy
is good
can you just show us what that would
look like yesterday yes it's very easy
esther says skinny
do me
i want to just sing that song if i die
young
we should do a fake uh funeral for you
like in um
uh
rex manning day what was that that show
empire records i did that one year that
wasn't a ass down face up i was thinking
on all fours yeah your head up like a
hyena with your ass down
with your ass tucked in
like this
that's what i thought that's also a yoga
pose it's a randy no one um one holiday
uh i
i think it was thanksgiving
my mom asked me to help set up which
actually maybe she didn't she would
never do that because she doesn't want
to be disappointed yeah i but i did set
up like pictures of me and candles
because i thought it would be funny if
we made the house look like i it was
like my shirt and the house burned down
you sit in with the dead right shifted
awesome it's
number one my favorite jewish it's like
after the funeral you just go to the
person's house and there's like a bunch
of candy and food and you just kind of
like party but there's they cover the
mirrors right for a week don't they
cover the mirrors i don't know the
technical rules because i wasn't i am
more jewish than you you're well i doubt
that i went to like jewish school and
stuff jewish preschool why don't you
know anything
because i didn't
my dad we're jewish culturally you're
the issue we're anti-religion tell us
the story of esther
okay esther was the beautiful queen
and
she was a jew but she was beautiful
and the king wanted the pharaoh
the pharaoh okay the pharaoh fell in
love with queen esther and queen esther
was like i'll seduce you pharaoh but you
have to let my people be free and he was
like okay for you and that hot [ __ ]
i'll let your jews free they should
teach that in hebrew school yeah do you
think he thought she said juice
the whole time she thought it was a
squirter thing and then he was like oh
[ __ ] i have to release all these juices
so esther they thought you were going to
be
a queen i was born on purim
which is queen esther's holiday and then
also my grandmother's name was esther
wait is purim the same as uh does it
call something else
no
purim is like
uh they do the sukkot
they do you go outside i don't know
we're about religious quorum's what we
used to call when i used to go to bar
mitzvahs and um
purim or
shots of manichevits we used to get so
drunk off of that nasty ship no offense
to the jewish community
better help listen sometimes the islands
give you the blues huh esther
well you know there's allergies there's
stress there's period emotions i need i
need my better help and honestly being
friends with you i need my better help
more power to you listen guys after you
have vacation with both of these girls
you're gonna need better help
if you thought vacation was gonna fix
your problems boy were you wrong
you're really gonna need someone to talk
to and thank god we can access them
while we're here on the road check out
betterhelp.com trash tuesday betterhelp
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist and you can connect in a safe
and private online environment
environment it's so convenient and you
can start communicating in just under 48
hours
you can send a message to your counselor
anytime
and you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions all without ever
having to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room we want you to start living
a happier life today as a listener
you'll get 10 off your first month by
visiting our sponsor at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over 1 million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health again that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com
trash tuesday
i'm glad we're talking about this
because you know what todd bought a quip
without me he did if i'm in a
relationship with you and you get a new
cool toothbrush you better bring me a
toothbrush
i want two toothbrushes i'm a two
toothbrush kind of girl manually
brushing your teeth with no electrical
charge behind it is really for
um
it's very 90s wouldn't you say annie
it's time to up your game guys yes uh
bad breath is not the business we're not
into it esther i'm glad we brought you
here today the thing i love most about
my quip is just how sleek and cool it is
it really is and they mail you your
refills by the way so you never have to
think about it you're always gonna get a
refill of toothpaste you're going to get
a refill of the toothbrush heads and
then on top of that you know how like
most toothbrushes you have to kind of
mount on your kitchen counter on your
counter
beautiful cute little pouch holder no
and it sticks to your wall it's so cute
also i am going to say this i have had
boyfriends in the past that do not
replace their toothbrushes you know when
your toothbrush looks like it has a
middle part
that's the guys i've dated before and
they all need it equipped because you
need quip to just remind you with that
package of that refill you guys from
celebrations
eating all the sugary treats we want and
all the other stuff we've been up to
our mouths put up with a lot this time
of year and you should treat yours to
quips line of sleek sustainable oral
care products when you bundle and save
up to 40 percent online through the
holidays plus by encouraging good habits
quip products really are the gifts that
keep on giving um timed sonic vibrations
with 30 second pulses to guide a dentist
recommended two-minute clean so it tells
you when
you're done annie basically it's like
you cannot stop brushing this it's great
because some people don't know a
lightweight on this podcast
a lightweight and sleek design for
adults and kids with no wires or bulky
charger to weigh you down it has a
multi-use travel cover that doubles as a
mirror mount for less clutter reusable
handles and a range of sleek metal hues
including best-selling all black and
all-pink as well as bright plastic
colors sure to make a pop to your
bathroom counter if you go to get
slash trash tuesday right now on top of
their holiday savings you'll get your
first refill for free that's your first
refill free and up to forty percent off
bundles at get quip dot com
trash tuesday
spelled
g-e-t-q-u-i-p dot com slash trash
tuesday quip the good habits company
so i have a question for you guys um
in about a couple hours we're gonna be
taking a tour
of a very special place called the
shangri-la
where there are
artifacts
i don't think they're stolen
but artifacts they're about to be get
your purse
and um i want to know what your
expectations are this place have you
looked it up this is an activity i
planned annie i think it's gonna suck
but i'm excited for it she's true a
museum i'm like oh god no it's an estate
that's cool the fact that it's like an
estate we're going to see how someone
fancy lived back in the day yeah you are
such
it's someone's home it was someone's
home once upon a old dead rich people
and you could not be nosey around and i
it's i am do you love it
where it's like how the house was but
they just have the thing where you can't
go in and you have to peek around yeah
this particular activity i will say i
had you in mind for but annie i will
take you to the um
olomana hikes
three peaks i feel like that's more uh
your style one of my like ultimate dream
vacation goals is i want to go to um
graceland elvis house but i want to go
in and see his room we can
how
only nicholas cage got to go in when he
married lisa marie presley oh
seduce her
i i can try we have to marry him um so
what would you say your your vacation
style is like what's a couple
how would you
describe
what's your elevator um description of
your vacation style
i haven't figured it out yet i'm i just
started trying vacations and i don't
like them yet i have to be working i it
can't be it can't be like a full
vacation i don't want time off
the ranch when i went to that place
where they make it i was at rehab right
go on hikes yeah and so rehab is nothing
rehab is her vacation style
a nurse they take care of you right yeah
someone says wake up
into a coma is her favorite that's her
okay so rehab is your vacation style
annie
actually you are a good coma candidate
because well you said in the car that
she'd be a good nursing
oh yes yes yes because
i think instead of being a nurse esther
should be like the
the patient what is it the acting the
crisis actually like i go for the
nursing school i go and i pretend i have
a disease so that the nursing students
can
learn how
we only deal with dummies
wait i think i see a lizard and i just
want to see it as a gecko
yeah i love geckos the green one oh we
lost her
we lost her to a gecko she sees her
cousin yeah you know we have massive
alligator lizards in california too
right you like those oh yeah no i see
those i love them yeah yeah i see
lizards in my yard i love geckos and
lizards sorry
they're sorry i had to enjoy my vacation
for a moment
you love lizards and geckos yes
have at me
you've just been keeping this a secret
that's your thing
all esther's getting from me you know
when you're like a kid and you're like i
like pigs and then everyone just gets
you pig things for the rest of your life
esther is only getting lizard attire
and there is lizard apparel there's you
have some competition a lot of people
like geckos what was the one animal you
that you told everyone was your favorite
animal when you were younger dog
okay yeah that's
pig is a joke but yeah i always had
pictures of like my dog or something on
my shirt oh that was always like a fun
present you used to wear a necklace when
i met you that said pig on it yeah
and then you
quick then you were like i'm not wearing
it anymore yeah what was that journey
the journey was
i got a nameplate necklace that said pig
which i thought was funny i love that
and
it was funny
oh bless my little baby's heart she's
struggling somebody give her a nappy
carlos come be in front of her when she
sneezes
feed me breastfeed her oh there's a
second one only geniuses niece and twos
there she goes struggling i am i
wouldn't call sneezing a struggle should
i sit this one out it's one eighth an
orgasm you should be so happy right you
sitting out has been an option
oh my god
get on the bench [ __ ] you should be
thanking god for every sneeze it's a
bodily release i know he's so funny
taking shits and sneezing these type of
sneezes sucks thank god this time
reframe your mind
can i finish let me finish the story
about the flight attendant
okay so i pushed esther's face into the
seat where jules's ass would have been i
just shoved her down i was
just anally raping her on the flight and
this the flight attendant comes up and
she she's like oh
excuse me
and so esther goes like all the way into
the back where the toilet is to go stay
in her seat
and
i go to the woman i go oh sorry like
thanks for being cool with us like and
she goes that's all right i have i have
children your age and i'm like
[Laughter]
ma'am pushing 40. i don't think you
understand uh the age that we are do you
know that one time my neighbor goes to
dave
sometimes i hear your children play in
the yard it's so fun dave's like oh
okay so he thinks you're my kid and your
friends are also my kids
what do you do in the backyard i don't
know what what kind of sounds are you
making she was crying when you play with
the lizards fire maybe i'm like
oh
a lizard
ah
or maybe carlos and i are
playing like dogs in the yard or she was
like dave get me sugarfish
[Laughter]
wow she calls her dad dave by his first
name
i could see it a star i could see you
being one of those people that calls
your parents by their first names no
that's how you can have more control
over them it's a power move a kid can do
this is an epic story that that annie
told me when we're in the pandemic
and i want you to tell kalila because so
you were working with a writer and it
wasn't going i had yes you tell i got i
had this opportunity to to do this like
write a pilot for
fox okay so this is like a real job
that's like a really big deal for when
this is a really big deal three years
into comedy hey it's hard to be a girl
in comedy
uh it's so hard um but anyway so i had
this opportunity so they're pairing me
with a writer and this was like the
third writer like the first there was
like always a problem there was always
like a scheduling thing or whatever so
but they were the idea was that you were
a young comedian that that fox was like
we want to do something with her let's
pair her with a more experienced someone
who knows what to do yeah and so they
paired me with this woman who
um
she just didn't
like me like she just didn't like me
like she just it was so it was just like
vibe off where
and she kind of like looked like right
if i was a right if i had gone into
writing it's like she literally like
there was like a
thing so maybe she was annoyed like who
is this like
[ __ ] girl who's been doing comedy
three years who's getting this
opportunity and like is not so there was
one time i had to be late right because
i had a meeting so i called i only asked
interrupt
when you're with someone and they don't
like you
what happens i go i
something turns on like you think i'm
already on
people like are you always on
no i'll show you double on the minute
you start rejecting me it just goes
faster faster faster it just speeds up
it's louder
like kalila knows when she was ignoring
me on the plane i was like it's
not going to stop
vander is actively dying right now all
right episode four
and annie is
playing with my toes
sucking on my throat
[Laughter]
um anyway so
i'm you know i'm being the most annoying
i can be but i have to be late for the
so i call her her head of time i go i'm
gonna have to be late i have a meeting
that last night meeting she was okay so
i show up and she goes what was the
meeting for
i said oh i met with a literary agent
they want me to write a book and she
goes no offense but you're never going
to write a book and i was like
okay you hate me also i never read the
book but i don't mean though but it was
just like okay
and it was just like it was always like
a weird like just tension of a woman who
hates me and then i have to tell her my
craziest story so we can write this
[ __ ]
thing right yeah so i'm just like yeah
and then so he's fingering me on the
airplane or like whatever my and she's
like just hates everything i say
so then we like sit down to like get to
work i sit on her couch um we're just
like we do like an hour of work whatever
i stand up
to go to the bathroom
i have period blooded
i bled
through her cow like it was a white
couch
and it's just like there's no scenario
where there's the right person to do
this to me
but there is a scenario where it's the
wrong person and this is it i it was
so [ __ ] crazy
like it so i just go there's nothing i
can do there's nothing i can do except
go i have blood on your couch
i am so sorry
i am do you have hydrogen peroxide i
know you didn't think this could get
worse ma'am
i know your nightmare has just you just
realized it's an inception of nightmares
so i have to go i'm like scrubbing on my
knees like trying to scrub it out
there's no way to get it out and she's
like oh i was gonna get it reupholstered
anyway nobody's ever getting anything
reupholstered that's not a thing it is
and but she was not yeah there's no way
she was like it wasn't like her house
was like in construction like it was
like done
everything was white it's not like she
was like
i gotta get this white couch turned
black it's like no i kind of made me
feel like
she deserved it
oh that's interesting i that's
interesting because she was mean to
annie yeah she was mean to me and it's
like it's not even something that you
did on purpose my body was like we're
taking this [ __ ] down god was trying to
put a punishment through your body and
into her couch it's like when this
happens to a guy you're [ __ ] they're
getting the exchange but she was getting
to have a job with fox
i mean it never happened but let's be
real things got a little
the let's just say the calls went a
little quiet after that
so i am like so embarrassed i remember
grabbing her wrist and being like we're
bound for life we're bound for life
we're bound for life oh no no i'm like
we're bound we're bound for life now
this is the most important and she's
like no it's fine it's like whatever
um and then
it just never it completely fell through
the project and then years later i
texted her
and i i just out of nowhere i was like
hey i just want to apologize i think i
was like very immature in my
career i didn't know how to work with
people i didn't know what day of the
month my period started just yesterday
still don't i currently don't say no but
i was like you know i just was like i
really want to apologize and like i just
want to clean that up and just let you
know like i i do
apologize for the way that things ended
and i hope you know on my part there's
no like hard feelings or anything and i
hope you're doing well and i do also
want to tell you that every time i stand
up for from a chair i think of you
and she never wrote me back
oh my god she never i never talked to
her again but she's doing good
i picked up her imdb yeah she wrote a
hit disney movie oh really yeah i feel
like we should prove it wrong and just
get you to write that book yeah yeah no
i'm going to write a book about her and
that's a chapter in there yeah there
will be a blood on me
yes
because sometimes you know that's where
the villain arc starts and i was so
broke this was when i was living in my
car too the first time and so i was like
couldn't i wasn't like i could pay for
her cat like there was i had no money
yeah
i was like oh i got to get out of here
she was like you can go
you could always call her now and be
like i do want to find her number and
like hit her up and see if i can get her
i want to like chase her
you want to get away from me [ __ ] we're
bound for life i already told you
i'm coming for you [ __ ]
i also okay so this is another thing i
like to do on vacation now that i'm no
longer living in my car
i like for the second or first time or
the for the yeah the third time will not
come third time you're it's that's it
yeah no it's definitely not the second
time
where you should realize
but you know what honestly george has
been a little busy preoccupied with this
family
we're gonna get rid of your family
george we need we need full attention
all right
so we're making i had to get george
coffee this morning you know what i'm
saying that's a good point i'm gonna
make you know how he's a producer and
he's production but i had to get him
coffee this morning wow what's going on
also i'm why am i recording right now
i'm starving i am so hungry no one fed
me my breakfast i'm sorry i maybe had
three bottles today already he's had two
naps at uh i'm i'm a little distracted
i'm uh i gotta be honest i'm george
we're hungry i'm so hungry i offer you a
tip but
wait is your wife breastfeeding no no no
okay all right it's about oh my god
there's only one way to there's only one
way to make this up to us george give us
your wife's tip now is the woman whose
house we're at is she breastfeeding
still she might
i've never had breast milk i me either
well not since i was four and a half not
since she was four i've had num two
things i'll drink i just wanna go on
before you go yeah i will drink anyone's
breast milk so will i and i'll tell you
i drank my best friend's breast milk and
i breastfed her baby
and my baby's sick when you say anyone's
breast milk are you like coming from
like a place of is there something i
don't know about where people are
discriminating over specific breast milk
no but it's not like some guys will be
like she's hot i'll take her breast milk
i'm like no
i want milk part of the internet are you
on
what subreddit are you what is going on
breast milk has a lot of benefits i know
there's like a whole series on netflix
about it on netflix i thought i say it
is it called like so cute netflix i love
it netflix netflix
back to our prominent figure
two night stand no one's taking the off
i don't like a two-night stand because
here's the thing if i'm gonna like shave
there will be razor burn by the second
day i can't deal with you thinking i'm
having a herpes outbreak on the second
day i do hate that though why is that
i'm getting lasered by the way any laser
company that wants to pay for it i'm
down i got my first bikini wax since
before covid for this trip and why did
you get it for this trip because i
thought we were going to be like on the
beach in swimsuits and i was like i just
don't want to think about it i don't
want annie to see
what really happened i have seen
but like in front of people when whitney
no in front of the most famous people
we've ever met that forgot whitney had
like a pool party at her house over the
pandemic which is just whitney gets sent
like the weirdest ugliest swimsuits all
the time
some are cute and some are like
shockingly the ugliest suits i've ever
seen and that's when she calls annie and
esther so she'll be like let's do a
photo shoot if you guys in ugly bikinis
so ben like does our makeup like drag
queens we have like huge like crazy
makeup and then whitney puts us in like
these horrible swimsuits and then
invites over like olivia munn amanda
cerny he's like the most beautiful
people amanda like this was a murderer
amanda costco
they've had a kid you don't know that
they are they actually did bond very
fast those two yeah they're cute but
anyway so
it would this was the first time we were
meeting everyone and esther had
a bush down to her knees it was like boy
shorts of pubes
it was crazy i'm jewish see you think
you're more jewish than me but you ain't
i do i just say i just take care of it
mine grows down there too
i'm more jewish than you
i it just looks i
maybe it's not appropriate to say it but
i always say that it looks like there's
a terrorist's face
down below
and where why is their tongue out
now did you think annie and i were going
to pass judgment when we saw your
bearish hair on your lips this trip at
one point looked like it was going to be
a lot different than how it's it is
going to be this is day two and it's
sunny and beautiful the birds are
chirping we're doing everything a
blizzard there's a there's a blizzard
warning the world's first
yeah for hawaii
that's so funny this is very on brand we
know god was not going to give us a
perfect vacation
you guys attitude
the best the best my favorite actually
so good i never thought sleeping on
bamboo would feel good the dirty little
not so secret about the bedding aisle is
that while cotton might be the most
popular fabric for sheets duvets and
pillowcases it's also the most damaging
to our planet even organic cotton takes
its toll that's why we here at trash
tuesday are so thrilled to introduce to
you attitude
tell us more about it esther well it's
made from naturally organic bamboo and
attitude sheets are made without toxic
chemicals and use 500 times less water
than cotton plus they're silky soft so
they're comfortable for you and the
environment and i have to say i've tried
a lot of sheets these are absolutely my
favorite by far whenever they're on my
bed i'm so happy and she's on that bed a
lot yes that is true and they're
anti-cotton unlike cotton which consumes
massive amounts of water energy and
chemicals during production attitude
uses natural organic bamboo
straight from esther's homeland the
forest and they're so comfortable the
attitude sheets wick away moisture and
regulate your temperature to keep you
cool and comfortable throughout the
night you know i need that i am a sweaty
sleeper it is there is so much spray tan
on my hotel sheets i wish there were
attitudes and you can try attitude
betting for 30 nights if you're not
completely satisfied you can return it
for a full refund and right now you can
get 20 off your order plus free shipping
when you visit attitude dot com slash
tuesday and enter promo code tuesday
remember that's attitude e-t-t-i-t-u-d
as an eco attitude order today for free
shipping and 20 off your order at
editto.com tuesday promo code tuesday
oh my god you guys i love nutrifoal i
feel so good
i think everything's a quack product but
neutral is not if you are patient and
you take it as suggested and recommended
and you you give it a couple months your
hair will be
thicker and fuller i can attest to this
100 you guys 30 million women are
impacted by weakened or thinning hair
and if you're among them know that
you're not alone and that there's a
solution you can trust to deliver
results and i got to tell you i'm a
daily clipping user and it does damage
your hair so you do need to counter it
by taking some neutral you got to grow
back those little bald spots you're
creating in your head with their fake
hair in a clinical study 86 of women
reported improved hair growth after six
months more than 1500 top doctors
recommend neutrophil as an effective and
high quality solution for healthier hair
healthier hair growth takes time it
really does if you're finding a product
out there that says you get overnight
results it's not real yes um you'll
begin to experience thicker stronger
faster growing hair in three to six
months you can grow thicker healthier
hair and support our show by going new
to nutrafull.com
trash to save 15 off your first month
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and it is only available to us
customers for a limited time
plus free shipping on every order get 15
off at nutraflow.com
spelled n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l
dot com slash trash
okay guys i wanna let you know another
part of my vacation now that
the money is flows to us
um i wanna spend tons of money and so i
went shopping while esther was cramming
shinier shoes while esther was cramming
town i will shine your shoes for five
dollars
with your tongue with your [ __ ] lips
with my ass
there's nothing on your body that could
shine me will you buy me a will you buy
i'll buy you a lap dance i'll sell no
i'm going to sell you a lap dance to me
of you on me wait people pay you to get
away from me well here we're going to
strip club tonight aren't we going to go
to a strip club this is gonna be a great
crazy fun vacation yeah we're going to
strip clubs tonight is the night esther
i will say this though i did go shopping
without you guys in your face she's
pretending like this is the worst news
on the planet i just woke up at 4am
today why then take a nap when we get
there okay why no i'll go to the strip
why
because i i'm [ __ ] up i'm sick i'm
have my period and
i'm gonna sneeze again no if we go to
the strip club you know i'm coming to
life okay good oh my god this girl the
girls are gonna go on stage with blood
all over their legs from esther
[ __ ] snail trolling do you think that
we'll go on stage
yeah
what do you mean
are you trying to outshine the dance i
don't want to try this i just
natasha bettingfield she's an outshiner
i'm just wondering like what experience
do you think the strip club will be like
what is it like here um it depends where
we go if we go to ballerinas or roxza
or
femnu
we'll see we'll do it no we'll skip
around we'll see what really you know
speaks to the heart i can i just say
something to all of our lesbian slugs we
love you by the way i the same lesbos
are coming out i love you you're hot
they're all like
girls sitting on each other's laps in
the audience and stuff it is i i will
say that on the road guys i'm never more
flattered than when a lesbian couple
slides into my dm and say we want to
innocently but not so innocently meet up
with you while you're on the island is
very tempting offer so that's
interesting that's happened to you
that's super same yeah
wait you guys i read todd's dm's today i
was like todd i'm reading your dm's and
i look there's nothing in them it's so
sad like i'm like no girls ever slide in
and say anything
he's like no
i'm like there's nothing well he's not
on a podcast every week he's not like a
a celebrity podcast oh i forgot you
don't get any dna
oh my god have you been getting some
since our last episode came through and
i just want to say i appreciate you guys
you got dick pics
no no dick pics and i don't i'm like i
like handpicked hands but oh that's cute
a lot of really sweet men were like hey
like we just want you to know like we
think you're pretty too
it was in a really and we have given all
of your names to the authorities you
pedophiles okay
and you're going down we're checking
your your
i'm a taken woman i cannot respond but i
just want to say that i appreciate it
who's who are you taken by
uh
i'm just i'm surprised by the taken and
the woman part
but i want to show you guys what i did
buy yesterday oh yes please this is my
first hawaiian purchase
my shopping i feel like it's going to be
partly something sparkly
and very not
oh my goodness oh my god
annie can you wear this tonight to the
strip club is that steampunk
oh i hate stuff i don't get serious
isn't it so funny oh bobby would love
this i went back i window shopped it i
went back i priced it out it's right
chappelle hats it is so good dave
chappelle hats tashable hats and
ironically it looks great on trans
people so that is a weird thing
okay what are our outfits tonight i
should have gotten all we know what
annie's are
do they have to wear this tonight okay
you know what my outfit is at the
airport out there you're looking at it
which is a triple x
out of it sweatpants so i can really
feel what they do you bringing in the
band-aid vibe he's bringing the band-aid
you want them to feel your boner yeah
we gotta get her some mesh shorts
oh i have some mesh esther does look
like she played some recreational sport
really you dress like someone that's
like my new fashion
like vision board style
inspiration is sleazy guy at a strip
club or at a casino
like that i feel like annie has nailed
that over the years i know obviously
esther's whatever your vision is what
i'm already doing
copy me copy me you're not see i'll
bring a steve bannon twist to it that
you'll never be able to have you know
what you add to that vision board you
don't want just any sleazy guy at the
strip club it's the guy who's gonna wait
for the breakfast buffet at the strip
club because they have buffets yeah at a
certain hour
i love crab legs i love legs with crabs
in between them i just love it all right
i love it all right
now i would like a stripper strippers
have tried to teach me to torque before
and it never works they say it's about
the heels tonight is the night yeah
i do go in very educationally i go like
teach me can we have a lap dance contest
after like we'll go to the strip club
we'll kind of like get maybe we'll get
some and learn and then afterwards the
three of us have to see who gives the
best lap dance take this one annie i
know you're filming at the mouth
it's just
do you should we call dave and just end
the engagement why you're gay because
you're gay
you're gay you want to leave them now or
later
ooh candy
you're gay
i am my sexuality is a spectrum and it
doesn't always have a word
divorced
can i borrow that top tonight
sure
i feel like that's a great for the lap
dance club this is good this is a good
top for you
i need to buy a new outfit though let's
go shopping we should go shopping
you're the real jew you keep that coin
purse so tight no but i'm here to i'm
here to esther and i are both here to
open your coin purse okay i'm gonna
[ __ ] open it
and money's gonna squirt out let's spend
money let's spend money let's spend i
don't i fee i don't like spending money
on myself no but let's do it let's just
change that for this trip let's just
have this i'd have to buy you guys a now
okay but we'll buy each other and then
you'll buy me yes yes yes that's the
only way it's gonna feel like justified
because i just feel like wait she's
still a liar this is the one that on
that when we said let's get gifts for
each other she's like no
you're right i don't want to spend that
on you also let's just be real okay when
we're all excited about the money we're
making kalila's looking down at us like
with her tiger belly money going
you guys think this is a lot i'm
literally like i can't wait to spend my
time
look at her hat
her hat says it all
i want to see you and what your home
looks like
in a year or two when you're a
multi-millionaire yeah that it's going
to be the living in the thailand
people you're going to have to get
you're going to go through a lot of
gates to get there
you know there's that plate on la brea
they have that yard where it's like just
a fun like circus lights and everything
i feel like that's what your home would
look like but mine would be like the
clean stuff not the new not the old
stuff mine would be like
brand new made i'm not getting any of
your [ __ ] hand-me-downs [ __ ]
that place is like dirty that's you and
me
yeah i would like like if it's a cool
antique but i'm not going i'm not
i'm hand-me-down queen you know what
i've been doing custom-made since i've
been getting high is like i like
i realize that when i get really in the
high zone i like to like transport
myself to different decades
oh no this is too embarrassing but like
my houses that i live in is really old
and has never been updated so like
sometimes i'm in my kitchen and i'm just
like oh i think about like the 1950s
chinese doctors that lived here and
before me
and how they would have like i like how
everyone is a doctor by the way in every
fantasy there's a doctor taking a doctor
that would take care of you no no
they're not there i'm just pretending to
be them living in their home you're
pretending to be a chinese doctor
speaking of doctors um
arlene who is very graciously allowing
us to record in her home her husband is
a urologist but at some point he did
labia he swept he switched to the vag so
i just thought we're here let's just
have him take a look and see what he
would do
i've never seen anyone beg so hard for
anyone
it's just it's not like i was wanting
that i'm like he's here we're here
i want to see how much would it cost
what would it look like what would you
do
what's your rating would you do it now
if it was a perfect looking [ __ ] but
they said um you lose about 25 percent
sensation no first i would never do it
period i would never get no no the
labiaplasty so if they said let's say
you were so insecure hate and you're
like this is the [ __ ] here's your uh
trophy [ __ ] but you're gonna feel a
little less no i'm too selfish for that
yeah me too feeling is more important
feeling is all important yeah kala what
do you like
look you would you guys hate about
yourself i feel like i just gave myself
labiaplasty
with these pants annie and i did come in
cowboy boots and i know that's maybe not
the expected hawaiian look but there are
paniolos here there are cowboys are a
real thing here on this island or
everywhere in hawaii listen i
i just was like i want to come to this
island and and cause a scene
and i i think i did yesterday in my
outfit
you did hike in cowboys i hiked in my
cowboy boots and my shorts are you
serious yeah does it hurt hurt it was
hurtful yeah
no it was good it was good
i um she flashed some tourists yeah todd
was taking a picture of me on the top of
the mountain and the wind was just
blowing my tip you know i almost flashed
you on the plane
oh
because i when i took my shirt off
because i wanted
klyla to look at my armpit to see if the
booster made me swollen and then you're
like oh your boobs look small and i
almost pulled them out and like how
small
she wanted to throw your body's faces
great i mean are you just ridiculous yes
really
when i'm making fun of you i'm not being
serious when i'm giving you compliments
i am being you know what you look like
what do you think if i'm being mean i'm
kidding if i'm just like sometimes
you've been looking good too well i've
been working out every day i don't know
what the hell your body looks like
someone who's removed that floating rib
you're very curious yeah there's
something going on like did you stop
eating a genre of food
are you like done with rice
it just feels like you like eliminated
something did you go vegan or something
no i just my walks are like my number
one thing in life
like i love them you don't consider a
hike a walk i don't want to hike i want
to walk i'll do a little bit of a little
hill but my walks i'm like
i'm creative i'm
i'm spiritual i'm it they're so
wonderful i'm i'm entrepreneurial it's
just weird that that weed made you
skinnier that is suspicious but i like
that you know because you're using it
for what it's supposed to be used for
which is like to expand but you know
what i think that smoking it and eating
it gives you a different effect because
a lot of people who smoke it say the
same thing that you say but you i broke
the eating though i i don't i just
stopped doing i just stopped but why
don't you want to eat your weed
it's less it doesn't feel as controlled
for me and it feels like it lasts longer
than oh i would have to agree with annie
um an edible for me is such a different
experience it's a gamble and it's more
of like a physical high that i'm not
um in control of
but with weed also with with joints i
realized mostly with weed it's not about
the high for me it's because i miss
cigarettes so i like
smoking joints
but also we're from the the class of you
know what i mean
late late 90s early 2000s where it's
like blondes blondes
[ __ ]
yeah no it looks
well i don't really break the law so
i've been trying to not i've been
thinking though i want to not smoke
because i've been being so healthy in
all the other aspects of my life that
i'm like why would i be just like
putting smoke into my lungs
i've been working out i'm so happy this
was like my goal was to just get in as
good of shape as i could for hawaii did
you love our little um 15 minute i did
it was nice well because sometimes
that's really all you need is to just
get the heart rate up i think that's
interesting that you guys planned a
whole little workout this morning we
were and i was completely left out of it
and i'm
there's no way
no universe where you were coming you
know what that is esther that's a big
tfti energy you're you're doing right
what's tfti thanks for the invite energy
oh i'm sorry i didn't mean it
because i didn't mean i was happy this
is absolutely pathetic no this moment is
pathetic why nothing that happened
before except you pan just begging her
to forgive you
i i'm i like it
i like that are you so grateful that we
didn't invite you to work yes i am
that's what i was in tfti
ntfti
i what
any type of letters
and he can't make a comment because she
doesn't know what letters are you know
it is funny i am not good at like my dad
can [ __ ] throw one out like he knows
what is it called my dad knows letters
that does but i don't know that's why
that's why our last name is letterman
don't [ __ ] talk to me about not
knowing letters that's my life
oh listen i was late to the podcast i
was at already
yes she found a way we came here
together and yet she was still late
i will say this we met i met george's
son for the first time he's eight months
old he's smarter than all of us he's
bigger than all he's so
cute he's such a good baby
those [ __ ] ray cons worked he cried
like three times i barely i could there
was a hint of it
i felt nothing i heard nothing i will
say i talked so much on the plane that
george's baby did ask to have his seat
changed
it was rude but do you know that i got
pretty woman two weeks ago what's that
and not enough fun to me too
wait not in like what a fun way that you
might think i got pretty like pretty
woman like as when as like
the scene where she goes to rodeo drive
yeah he gets treated like [ __ ] wait i've
been i've been doing a joke she's just
told me this happened are you eating
this
dude this chick everything i picked up
at auritzia at your shop i love your
friends yeah i went to original and this
girl was so rude everything that i
picked up can i get that for you yeah
you can start a fitting room for me
she goes to the fitting room goes right
behind me there were so many other
people there granted i did look like
absolute trash i was dressed like you at
the airport
and just full-on same outfit she was
wearing at the airport by the way like
extra you know what nobody pretty
woman's me because i look confident i
look like a slob like you work they
think you work there and then by the
seventh item you guys
she was just are you gonna take that are
you gonna buy that which one what city
glendale oh i think at some point my mom
comes over and she was like
she's like are you is she doing that i'm
like yeah she's doing that
and i couldn't [ __ ] wait i bought so
much just to prove her a point i racked
up my bill just so
she could ring me up and then i could
look away while i handed her my card as
if it was nothing like i just had i
didn't even want the those things i
didn't even want to buy all those things
but now i had to i had to do it just to
prove her that i could afford it so the
store wins she won
she should get a promotion she should
get a promotion
what if we find out i bet you she was
just a fan wait weird what is um what
was your story oh i was okay so i was in
la jolla by the way thank you everyone
that came out to la jolla sold the shows
out it was so fun thank you thank you
um but la jolla has like a flea market
type thing
and so i bought something at every table
okay so like i bought like i bought like
a wooden thing that you open and like a
wooden snake comes out closer goes back
in
i went to the next table i bought like a
a prism crystal thing to go in the
window
then i get to this like i really like
body jewelry okay
i know they're the best and this is one
by the way
so okay so then there's like this gaudy
jewelry and i go what's the most
expensive thing you have
and the girl goes
no and i just want to see like what like
what are all of these like what and i go
like is is this the most expensive and
she's like what are you going to buy and
are you going to buy something because i
don't want to explain this to you
and i just was like
but i was like started like i went i
went you know what it's really weird i
need to see things before i buy them and
i don't understand what the hell this is
i have a lot of money and i would have
spent all of it here i bought stuff at
all of these people's places you're
literally the first place i'm not buying
something at and i walked away and i was
like did a meditation to try to drop it
and i walked back and she apologized oh
she did but she was like she was like
i'm really sorry
i was like i just need like i just think
it's my right as a shopper to shop
i don't need i'm not don't have the
products platform no or miss america
but why do i need to tell you what i'm
buying before i've seen it no you're
absolutely right yeah so weird
and you're doing nothing you're no one
it was the end of the day she should
have just closed her store if she was
going to be rude but it was just weird
because i would have i was like about to
buy something and you know what she did
apologize here's what it is i worked
retail for years and even if i thought
someone was stealing i just let it go
i'm not that's not my job i'm there to
fold [ __ ] and get you your size i'm not
there to play police or be a secret
shopper so i was just really bummed out
that someone thought that i'd look that
[ __ ]
penniless
i just you know
um just a convenience store something
with jenna
a place where i always went and she came
with me once and the [ __ ] store owner
followed her around i was like this
[ __ ] sucks so this is weird i hate
this he followed her around maybe he
follows kevin bacon
do you know kevin bacon are you the girl
to be fair i did
steal a lot when i was younger and maybe
this is karmic
i did bring wire cutters to
places and i have wire cutters well yeah
if you want to steal [ __ ] when you know
you want that [ __ ] baby fat jacket in
our late 90s if anyone works at
bloomingdale's corporate for sorry
i will pay
top dollar to get the polaroid of when i
got caught shoplifting when i was 14
like i want that picture so bad my dad
and i have gone
into the back of bloomingdale's like
just walked into the office part and
been like where can we find this picture
and they're like it's in a warehouse
somewhere if one of you works in that
warehouse the willow grove mall i will
pay you money i want that so bad i was
so upset i was so scared we would have
all been a good team because in high
school i didn't steal but the cool girls
did and then they would give me the
shirts and i would give them to my mom
and i'd be like mom
because you had to rip out
the leaf yeah while i was talking
surprisingly not a big as big of a
reaction as annie and i anticipated
that things follow me all the time and i
just keep going are you that kid who who
got um smacked by the ball in the face
all the time and then you your best
believe i went to the nurse's office for
it for no reason before
and i also never had to participate in
swimming in high school i don't okay so
basically how the girls would steal is
they would rip the hole in the shirt and
they'd pull the sensor out so then i
they would hand me the shirts and my mom
was like she could sew and so i was like
mom like shannon's older sister works at
abercrombie and they just give away all
the ripped shirts and so my mom would
sew the holes in the shirts and then
we'd give i'd give them to all the girls
i worked at abercrombie what have they
arrested your mom for hearing this right
now there's just someone at your door
what are the laws regarding this us
admitting um
things we've stolen george
noticed that i didn't admit anything
just artistic freedom guys these are all
just animators these are made up made up
stories i was a thief no but i had
something else
once i got yeah i know i like here
you're like the pretty good no [ __ ] you
were like get that
they like go to prison you're like i
don't know i never met them
i no i once i got caught i didn't do it
again wow so it really does work to to
to slap on the wrist doesn't it i was
like well i just didn't want to
disappoint my parents oh i did that [ __ ]
for a while surprisingly or not enough i
don't like disappointing my parents
yes i remember this this girl that i
went to high school with she was so cool
i actually loved her she was so badass
she was like i got caught stealing and i
was like what'd your parents say and she
was like they just said why didn't you
ask us to buy it for you and i was like
so cool that's so cool
that was not an option for me no i know
of course same
remember echo baby fat yeah
all of that stuff
oh i know i had thomas did you guys shop
at rave
i like i did shop at rave wait what's
wrong like super cheap chintzy like
clothes yeah i was always i was like
songs for three dollars i was a baby
[ __ ] so i did deb rave um
charlotte ruse was charlotte ruse
twenty dollars for those
i stole one of my sister's thongs out of
her underwear drawer and i like kept it
in my underwear drawer
and just like would wear it sometimes
were you a whale tailed on your face
that is disgusting i still am a
whaletail queen by the way yeah i feel
like whitney's party we went to
whitney's christmas party all of us at
separate times are you guys one at the
same time i saw for two seconds i saw
her on my way out
which was also your way in
esther can really pop in and out can i
tell you there's always a photo booth
and i see esther and then i turn around
and she's gone i'm like just one picture
[ __ ]
you know what i was really upset about
is that we all went to the same party
and all missed each other yeah that
sucks
you guys were long gone by the time i
got there it was fun i imagine you got
there right on time i got there like 15
minutes early i was which is my style my
style of partygoer is i go about an hour
in so that's when i arrived and you guys
were on your way out you and carlos were
on your way out and then i guess as soon
as i left you got there yeah i got there
around like probably 9 30. but did you
see sarah tiana's baby so i want to meet
him so bad he's really cute you guys may
know who we're talking about because
it's the young boy that whitney is like
mouth-kissing on instagram very
aggressively on instagram
very aggressively
if you bring whitney like your child or
your puppy her mouth gets involved my
dog's mouth was inside his head was
inside her mouth within 10 seconds of
her meeting anyway
i um it was very fun but what was i
going to say about the party your whale
tail oh troy conway was there taking
pictures and so my costume my christmas
costume was that i had a black sheer
shirt on black pants but i had a red
bikini top and then i had a green thumb
so i was just gonna have the thong
coming out so i was like troy take
pictures of me bending down pretending
to look at like the christmas sweaters
and he took them and we're all laughing
but when the pictures come out whitney
sends they send you like all of the
pictures like they send you a link so
everyone at the party like chrissy
teigen john legend like all these random
people are getting
this these pictures of my i look like a
full stripper like my ass is fully out
so it's like pictures of sarah teon and
her kids like different people and their
kids and then
a grown woman a grown like out like a
woman who's like
pushing it you know what that's still
dressing like this that's slug behavior
oh yeah
that's how i was feeling i was like no
apologies baby let's do slug behavior at
the strip club tonight we will this is
how i feel about my whale's tail though
too because people complain about it or
they'll go like you're under i go i my
thong has been shown since i was 14
years old mm-hmm you need to manage your
emotions around yeah exactly
bring back the whale tails by the way
that's that's what tells back we should
make thongs by the way emily
radakowski's book like she kind of makes
this point like why my whole life did
everyone tell me like i had to cover up
my body like why can't you just deal
with how you feel about my body by
yourself yeah i'm a nudist at heart look
i get it i think we all are
and i would have to agree with that
statement i will say i have one more
thing to say is um i want to know
three things that you want out of this
trip so i make sure that i deliver on
all of your wishes annie i know one of
yours you want to dive with me yes let's
die i was going to say gucci brother
i want to dive i want to go beautiful i
want to go to a place that's beautiful
okay like an energy vortex yes okay good
good food and coffee okay
nice fancy dinners i want to drop money
with you guys i want us to spend money
so you want to you want to go to dinner
date with us maybe seaside
beach side yes okay
good
good poke and sushi we already yes okay
fun exciting coffee
i feel like we have already checked off
my list everything's in the hotel she
wants by the way uh she's like
complimentary towels
um
one more thing out of the box and a
conditioner that comes in the room i the
only things i like are eating
fresh strawberries
okay let's get in a really fun struggle
okay experience yeah lap dance maybe
even an escort
there's this gay bar right next to where
i'm staying that i really want to hit up
okay
maybe before we go to our strip club
adventure so today is jam-packed day
i think so okay
tag us at convertible i'm starving okay
let's go eat let's go eat yeah let's eat
i want to go shopping i want to get a
nice outfit so no we're saying no to the
buddhist temple i want to do buddhist
temple okay
in your steampunk can i have the answer
after we eat yes yes let's go eat guys
let's go get shaved ice too
shaved ice is not breakfast and oh it's
really weird to me that you think it is
oh also by the way we get into hawaii
this is kalila's island she's so excited
i was not born and raised here you live
here you're a resident
kalila is a resident
kalila's like todd and i can't wait to
get seafood or something like why isn't
he so fun kalil's like yeah if you want
to meet up later for an acai bowl a
dinner awesome i'm like is it brunch
you know what if you've not had the cove
acai bowl then you wouldn't understand
why i offered it i want it i want it too
can we get it now can we get it now yes
i want to go to the north shore too and
get shrimp tacos yeah north shore we
could do make a whole day out i can't
wait to north shore we're recording in
north shore for one
you guys know that when i was in hawaii
i was 17 i worked at the kuala basin
marine mammal lab which i want to take
you guys to but i was 17 years old i was
here everyone was old it was like i had
like a british bobby it was like a woman
who was in her 50s who was a
a
cop in london this like asian guy that
worked for um the epa
in dc and he was like very like nerdy
and like didn't want to hang out with me
so by myself at 17 i got on a bus and i
went to the north shore and i just like
read my little paperback book and ate
hawaiian food it's so fun up there we're
gonna make a day of it yes
um george is waving a food at us
to try full circle
pete got that for you
snapping turtle jerky
i know i feel guilty
how do i feel about this snack i feel
scared to eat a turtle my mom used to
give us snapper supermar a little and
once we realized what it was where's the
vegan option pete you guys i um where's
my banana that one oh [ __ ] where's my
banana oh my god my place is to not have
a banana break [ __ ] banana he managed
to have his banana colored glasses on we
know we should change it to papaya break
where's our [ __ ] papaya i can't make
it through without what the [ __ ] george
you see what i'm saying about production
all these people and their [ __ ] kids
it's like we gotta so you would rather
be on this trip with rick glassman
i can't be on a trip without other
jewish people so you would rather be on
this trip with rick glassman that's
wrong you're right i want you
thank you
and almost you almost hurt my feelings
also one more thing we should probably
plug arlene's yes yes yes yes so we've
been hanging out in this beautiful home
and what part of kailua kailua so we're
seeing where she lives we're going to
give you the address guys come by no but
we've been hanging out with these
beautiful adorable eight-month-old twin
babies having so much fun
babying it up and you're so good with
babies both of you are really good oh i
love babies i'm not as good as me but
very good with babies annie you might be
better than me i'm no because i don't
you know the right things to do i i feel
it i just comment below who you'd rather
have hold your baby
i mean i'll hold your baby but if
there's a shopping opportunity beyond
your baby that baby's getting dropped
okay
if there's something sparkly i can spend
too much money on that i'll wear once
i'm dropping that baby anyways arlene's
documentary is called um nurse unseen
and it's about nurses during the
pandemic and it sounds really i think
it's filipina
yeah and why there was a big migration
filipino nurses in the united states but
you guys go support it i think there's a
website for it um and she's been really
wonderful to have us here and we can't
wait to watch it and we love all our
nurses all of those shows on the road
have been incredible you guys coming out
i know we got a lot of nurses we got a
lot of different people from different
parts of the world it's great it's so
we'll link all that info below and also
don't forget to check out our new merch
at slugfam.com
let's go get shaved ice for breakfast
breakfast we're gonna have it she
doesn't have a choice it's not it's ice
[Music]
you